good morning John since
2007 we have been doing a yearly thing
called the project for awesome and it's
taken a lot of different forms during
that time like there was that year where
YouTube paid for us to do it in a live
studio in Los Angeles and like a bunch
of classic like look it's Smash and the
will of DC and then other years have
been like John we should rent a theater
for 48 hours and fill the audience with
people who can't leave the theater for
the entire and you're like Hank reain it
in but this year since the last 12
months have been pretty weird we're
going to change some things and almost
all those changes are just about
simplifying especially for the people
who work on the project for awesome
behind the scenes though that does
include you and me to start though
here's what stay in the same you can and
should make a video promoting your
favorite charity and then you can submit
that video to project.com between
January 30th and February 13th you can
vote for Charities featured in videos at
projectforawesome.com and a portion of
the money that we raised during the P
will go to the Charities voted on there
will be a weird live stream where
sometimes we're being very sincere and
talking to global leaders of
international Aid organizations and
sometimes we're spreading baked beans on
our face or something and there will be
lots of cool perks both physical and
digital that you can get in exchange for
donating to the project for aw and
finally forth just like last year if you
have the ability you can donate to the
matching fund so that your money can
encourage other people to donate but you
have to do that before February 12th so
that all seems very samsy what the heck
is changing Hank number one for the last
few years we have split the money raised
during the P between in the first half
the money has gone to save the children
and Partners in Health and during the
second half the money has gone to
organizations voted on by the community
and every year that has worked out to
within a couple of percent to 50% of the
money going to Partners in Health and
save the children and 50% going to
Charities voted on by the community I
think that the like first half second
half thing is a little confusing for
people who are new it's also complicated
for a couple of reasons internally and
it doesn't seem like it needs to be a
thing so this year's project for all the
money from all of the time during the P
will be pulled together I know this
might make like the metag gaming of the
project for awesome a little less fun
for some people but there's always
trade-offs right and then from that big
pool half the money will go to save the
children and Partners in Health and the
other half will go to Charities voted on
by the community second this is kind of
a bummer but like logistically it makes
sense like it's the right thing to do
we're not going to stream for All 48
hours just so that everybody on the team
can have some downtime there will be
some early morning hours during which we
will go dark and third this is not
something that we did but tiltify has
introduced a new feature where you can
actually like shopping cart up your
perks so instead of buying things one at
a time which takes forever you can be
like I want this one this one this one
and then check out one time this is
great thank you tiltify that's Fant I
love that I love that you saw that we
had this problem and you solved it we're
also doing a thing this year where in
addition to having the digital download
bundle we're going to have the physical
perk bundle which is going to be a bunch
of stuff but you can get all of it for
way cheaper because the way that getting
one perk at a time works is that we have
to ship each one out to to you
separately but if you get the bundle
they all come in one package and that
saves a lot on shipping and then more
money can go to charity the project for
awesome is one of the most special and
wonderful things in my life it is
wonderful it is also very fun I have
plans there's always a banana Loca in
that storage chest right there I am just
so grateful for all the people who work
really hard to make the project for
awesome happen behind the scenes there's
a lot of people who work super hard and
we're just trying to take a little bit
of lift off of them and also off of
ourselves also I just uploaded a video
where I talk about make a good project
for awesome videos so if you're
interested in making a video promoting a
charity of your choice you can check
that out project for awesome grants tend
to be like 20 to $30,000 so it can be a
pretty big deal for a lot of
organizations and I'm glad so so happy
that we get to do that work thank you
for being a part of this community John
I'll see you on Tuesday